pouvez-vous nous donner des nouvelles de
votre garçon
bah écoutez tout d'abord bonsoir
mon fils
va bien tout le corps médical qui s'est
occupé de lui toute la journée
a été rassurant au fil des heures qui
sont passées
ce matin c'était quelque chose
d'extrêmement tragique
pour tout le monde et
nous avons je sais pas si c'est le terme
exact mais en tout cas on a le sentiment
d'être
chanceux par rapport à deux autres
familles qui sont en deuillées ce soir
et
et qui sont qui sont anéantis nous on a
eu
peut-être avec une certaine maladresse
je m'exprime mais en tout cas on a on a
on a eu des nouvelles de moins en moins
pire par rapport à ce que ce qui avait
été constaté sur place ce matin par les
par les premiers intervenants et par nos
amis de la garderie par d'autres parents
et ensuite par ma femme en premier lieu
voilà ce soir nous sommes
nous avons la chance de ne pas être
endeuillé mais toutes nos pensées vont
verser deux familles
et porte cette douleur et avec
lesquelles
on est solidaire et avec lesquels on
peut absolument partager un petit
morceau de leur douleur vous savez on
peut pas se mettre vraiment à leur place
on ne sait pas ce que c'est qu'un tel
drame que de perdre un enfant vous
l'avez failli perdre le vôtre mais
j'imagine comment personnellement
accueillez-vous cet élan d'amour
d'affection ou de soutien ne serait-ce
que de solidarité avec avec vous les
familles des enfants
qui sont qui sont blessés qui ont été
témoins de cette tragédie
ça va vous paraître bizarre mais dans un
premier temps
moi après diverses appels qui ont en
vingtaine de minutes j'ai eu à trois
reprises
des personnes des amis très proches qui
étaient sur les lieux au moment du drame
puis ma femme a deux reprises et les
nouvelles ont été
la première a été catastrophique la
deuxième a été un tout petit peu plus
rassurante parce que j'étais conscient
que ma femme était sur les lieux et la
troisième fois que j'ai échangé avec ma
femme elle m'a annoncé que mon fils
avait été sorti
on va dire des des roues du bus par un
ami papa aussi d'un jeune garçon de la
garderie et
c'est assez surprenant mais quand je
suis arrivé sur place il y a cette
solidarité qu'on voit tous les jours
mais qui n'est pas dans des moments
tragiques on échange toujours ce regard
de bienveillance envers les uns et les
autres ce qu'on sait que nos enfants
jouent ensemble même si on se connaît
pas vraiment si on est des cultures
différentes on a toujours ce petit
regard qui nous souhaite une bonne
journée parce que ils vont se balader
ensemble parce qu'ils vont scanner
parfois ensemble mais on a toujours
cette bienveillance et aujourd'hui on
l'a multiplié
par des milliers
et donc on n'est pas surpris d'avoir cet
élan de solidarité
on est juste sa confirme ce regard qu'on
échange tous les jours avec l'ensemble
des parents ça confirme cette
bienveillance cette gentillesse
que on partage nous en tant que parents
et que nos enfants parfois traduisent
entre eux
dites-moi votre enfant était conscient
vous avez pu quel âge a-t-il et vous
avez pu échanger avec lui
réalisait-il la tragédie qu'il était en
train de vivre
alors
pour les premières minutes où ma femme
est arrivée sur place
c'était il manquait par rapport au
dénombrement
on va dire au recensement effectuer à la
va-vite par les par les personnes sur
place
ma femme n'a constaté que l'absence de
mon fils dans les couloirs donc elle a
eu ce moment de d'extrême tristesse et
de panique
quand elle a eu
des nouvelles de mon fils était par
encore une fois c'est les appelles tous
des amis les parents sont tous nos amis
il était avant ils le seront encore plus
aujourd'hui un ami qui qui averti ma
femme comme quoi il était prête de mon
fils et ma femme quand elle était
arrivée sur les lieux dans la classe mon
fils était sur une table et il était
conscient et il a reconnu sa maman
et
sans faire dans le sensationnalisme sa
première question c'est pourquoi il a
fait ça alors je pense que c'est
certainement des mots d'adultes qu'il a
entendu en étant éveillé dans dans les
dans les décombres
mais il avait ce sentiment déjà que
quelque chose avait été fait et que
le pourquoi un enfant de 4 ans et demi
pour répondre à votre question même pas
un enfant de 4 ans et demi se pose la
question et des parents de 40 ans se
posent la même et des personnes encore
plus âgées se posent la même
on est sans réponse et je sais pas si
une réponse
apaisera la douleur qui est la nôtre et
plus important celle de des deux
familles
vous êtes vous vivez
ma foi presque comme j'ai ressentir un
petit miracle ou un grand miracle ce
soir de pouvoir embrasser votre fils
c'est tout ça vous en avez un autre
enfant je sais pas quel âge il a on a
beaucoup parlé ce soir de la manière
dont on doit parler à nos enfants de ces
tragédie là de cette violence là
vous vous sentez bien accompagné vous
aurez l'occasion d'être bien accompagné
avec du soutien pour passer à travers
cette épreuve
oui alors c'est très important ce sujet
là parce que
trouver les mots on n'a pas de recette
miracle on parle avec nos émotions dans
un premier temps on essaye de se
réserver parce qu'on sait que nos
premiers mots auront une importance
primordiale dans dans le reconstruction
pour tout vous dire
ma femme n'a pas briefée mais c'est une
sorte de confiance entre conjoint qu'on
doit se faire parce que soit c'est le
papa en premier soit c'est la maman en
premier c'est rarement les deux et nous
on se fait confiance et on sait que les
premiers mots pour notre fils a été ma
femme j'ai une totale confiance en elle
pour l'avoir rassuré lui donner la force
de de s'accrocher à la vie
et moi de mon côté j'ai dû gérer ma
fille
dans ma présence un peu tardive ce soir
ma fille qui est plus âgée avait non pas
la malchance mais la chance parce que
c'est une structure extraordinaire qui
est l'école du parc elle se situe à 200
mètres de notre garderie et donc sa
grande sœur était la première
témoin de l'arrivée des secours et ça a
été d'ailleurs la cellule de crise je
crois a été créée dans son école à elle
donc elle n'avait pas énormément de
questions
mais elle se demandait pourquoi il y
avait autant de d'ambulance et de
véhicules de police et les seuls mots
qui ont été les miens ce soir c'est lui
dire que il y avait eu un accident
un bus était
encastré dans la dans la garderie de son
petit frère que son petit frère avait
été pris en charge par les pompiers et
que
voilà c'était un accident
pour les enfants de cet âge bien sûr
pensons vous pensez beaucoup aux parents
endeuillés ce soir
[Musique]
quel sentiment vous habite à leur égard
parce qu'on personne veut vivre ce
cauchement là ce drame on peut personne
veut l'imaginer personne peut imaginer
quand on dépose son enfant à la garde de
riz qu'on ne le revera pas que c'est le
dernier moment les sentiments vous
habite à leur égard qu'est-ce qu'on
qu'est-ce qu'on leur dit alors c'est un
sentiment qui qui nous est inconnu
depuis ce matin c'est à dire qu'on a on
était dans les spectative on était
en priorise effectivement notre
attention sur notre enfant
et ensuite quand on commence à avoir des
des nouvelles plutôt rassurantes on
commence à s'ouvrir aux nouvelles à
regarder des mises à jour
c'est pas de la curiosité malsaine c'est
juste savoir ce qui est arrivé et à qui
même si
n'importe quel autre enfant nous aurait
provoqué une douleur immense
il s'avère que comme je le disais à vos
confrères tout à l'heure on arrive tous
à peu près à la même heure on a tous
cette routine quotidienne il fait que à
cette heure-ci on sait à peu près quels
enfants jouent avec le nôtre et
ces deux familles là nous sont
très proches et
ce soir
je n'ai pas à l'expliquer à mon fils je
sais pas à quel moment nous aurons à
l'expliquer à mon fils mais mon fils a
perdu deux grands amis avec qui partager
des moments privilégiés tous les matins
et je pense à ce petit garçon à cette
petite fille qui
vivront dans le souvenir de leurs
parents mais qui vivront très fort aussi
dans notre esprit parce que c'est ce ne
sont pas que des visages c'est aussi des
prénoms des habitudes et c'est des
parents qu'on salue tous les matins et
qu'on comme je disais ce soit toujours
de la bienveillance de la bonne santé
pour la nouvelle année et plein de
bonnes choses à toutes les petites fêtes
toute l'actualité passe à travers nos
yeux en se souhaitant les meilleures
choses et ainsi de suite et aujourd'hui
c'est c'est le pire qui puisse arriver à
des parents
on imagine que vous allez dans les jours
les semaines être près d'eux que vous
allez tous ensemble essayer de traverser
cette épreuve aller chercher les soutien
psychologique nécessaire si l'enfant
cela dit il y aura un processus
judiciaire également
à l'encontre de cette de ce suspect
est-ce que un sentiment qui vous anime à
l'égard de cette personne
alors moi j'espère parler mon expérience
professionnelle à ce moment là
j'ai été plus d'une dizaine d'années
policiers en France
ce qui fait que ce genre d'actualité je
l'ai vécu dans les médias avec distance
je l'ai vécu aussi professionnels
directement en étant le premier mois
intervenant en ce moment-là mais comme
je l'ai dit un collègue de la SQ qui
était sur place aujourd'hui
je l'ai vécu moi directement aujourd'hui
pour mon enfant et surtout son
environnement proche
j'ai plus de détachement voilà sur
certains paliers c'est ma femme qui il
me soutient et qui me prête son son
épaule et pour la suite en tout cas je
sais que je serai d'une épaule très
stable et très réconfortante parce que
je dirais que c'est plus un
mindset professionnel qui prend le pas
plutôt que ce soit de les émotions
des mécanismes de protection et de
survie au fond pour vivre
[Musique]
une sorte de carapace qu'on utilise pour
pour se blinder soi-même les l'ensemble
du du corps intervenant que ce soit des
paramédics des pompiers des militaires
des policiers on connaît ce genre de de
protection
on l'utilise parfois
à temps parfois trop tard et puis de
toute façon l'être humain est faillible
donc on n'est pas nous-mêmes à l'abri de
quelques failles que ce soit le tout
c'est de savoir uni solidaire et
et on sera toujours là pour ceux qu'on
traversait la même chose on sera
toujours là pour ceux à qui on veut
éviter ce genre de choses et c'est la
solidarité de l'humanité qui
fera que
ces personnes-là restent debout et
dignes et on sera là pour pour aider les
autres familles
quelles qu'elles soient Sébastien
courtois père d'un petit garçon de 4 ans
mais vous pouvez nous dire son prénom
quand on envoie des bonnes pensées
c'est le petit Jules non alors
l'embrasse très fort
absolument extraordinaire vous serez
présent pour vos enfants mais pour ses
parents de vie à qui on offre évidemment
nos condoléances et je pense que tout le
Québec entier vous savez cette nouvelle
a fait le tour du monde je pense que
tout le monde a pris une part de cette
épreuve pour essayer de
comprendre
l'incompréhensible Sébastien courtois on
souhaite que que le petit Jules se
remettra rapidement il est entre bonne
main et aussi Sainte Justine merci
d'avoir appris le temps de nous parler
dans cette journée extrêmement difficile
pour pour vous tous merci beaucoup on
vous embrasse
merci beaucoup merci au revoir